[Musique]
excusez moi vous savez qu'on fait les
quatre ans de mariage pour tous le
mariage homosexuel est ce que vous vous
êtes senti sondages est ce que vous êtes
pour ou contre normalement ce n'est pas
bien pour vous ça n'est pas bien non ce
n'est pas du tout bien est ce que vous
êtes pour ou contre le mariage gai tout
ça il faut enchaîner tout ça est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec les gens qui
pensaient sincèrement qu'un enfant a
besoin d'un papa et d'une maman
nécessaire le jean fanchette ont touché
un papa et une maman c'est tout quelle
est votre réaction si vous voyez deux
hommes s'embrasser ça m'énerve tout
simplement touche en fait pas grand
chose chaque goutte chez tous ces gens
sont magnifiques ils sont en train de
compter voiture là bas c'est vrai moi
non [ __ ] t'es levé même chanté
l'interviewer excuse moi de te déranger
militaire voiture qui est en train de se
faire enlever ses deux collègues et de
quoi il parle et parle de comment du cul
c'est quoi comme question qui vous est
posée au poulet faisait comment entre
les [ __ ] quoi comme on dit si ça les
[ __ ] bah oui faut les folies tout et il
faut faire le ménage moi vous avez
remarqué que j'en étais un qua non bah
je suis je suis vraiment homosexuels
pardon monsieur allait retourner encore
un autre j'aime trop quelqu'un m'a dit
moi ce sont ces les gènes qui sont
malades c'est comme tout un chacun il y
en a qui on le bichonne et si ils le
vivent de ça
la wii ce qu'il s'agit d'un vice les
homosexuels vous les respectez bien sûr
on lit tout et tout et tout et tout et
les [ __ ] ou assassiner tout moment qui
sont pour lui et malgré ce pas pourquoi
que je vais contrôler tout et tout et
tout par exemple moi ça fait trois ans
que suis avec mon ami jérôme on a envie
d'adopter qu'est ce que vous pensez
c'est tout de suite ces deux mille pour
cent de la première phase du oui fallait
je te coupe vous vient de recevoir le
mail c'est ok pour l'adoption du pin a
ajouté djibril on la regarde il regarde
et on va axer on va en avoir alors vous
pouvez le dire félicitations
merci monsieur revoir bonne journée à
vous merci mon dieu
les gens sont ouverts d'esprit waouh ça
fait chaud au coeur
en tout cas ma cnai et moi on va
chercher le petit jibril dans trois
semaines donc si vous avez des messages
de soutien à lui adressé bien n'hésitez
pas en commentaires surtout en cette
période un peu un peu nauséabondes et
puis bien sûr abonnez vous et n'hésitez
pas à regarder d'autres vidéos et à
voter philippe oudot